Oui ?
Ouais non, je te laisse, ouais.
Je suis entrain de faire une fausse mise en scène pour le début de "Soirée Nanar".
Ouais. Salut.
Salut !
Est-ce que vous voulez regarder "Les aventuriers du système solaire" ?
Oh oui ! Ah bah oui. Très joli... Est-ce une vraie question ?
C'est avec plaisir. Bah vous avez pas le choix.
C'est celui que j'ai choisi.
Ah c'est un dessin animé !
C'est un dessin animé ? C'est un dessin animé !
Et surtout c'est déjà extrêmement long.
Rick Ashley...
C'est très proche de Rick Astley. Bah oui !
A tout moment, le film, c'est juste un générique.
Genre, un gigantesque.
Hey, c'est une deuxième chanson qui commence, là, on est d'accord.
Attends ! C'est pas un dessin animé...
C'est un dessin... C'est pas un dessin animé.
Incroyable.
Le professeur arrive !
Bonjour tout le monde !
Professeur...
Pourquoi nous attaque-t-il ?
Il a 37 ans !
On disait "Hitchcock: Le maître du suspens" mais...
Là, quand même, on est pas mal.
Je pense qui a une passion pour les plans très longs, hein...
Chez ce réalisateur.
On est censé voir des trucs...
Y'a un mec qui balaye !
J'ai jamais vu un mec balayer aussi effrayant, c'est...
Cette musique...
Qui êtes-vous ?
Des bandits !
Tais-toi, vermine !
J'espère qu'il va leur tirer dessus.
Cindy !
Du ketchup plein la bouche !
Oh non !
Elle est morte !
Ah fais gaffe, tu joues mieux que lui !
Surtout pour voir les sourcils froncés tout le long du film, comme ça...
Ouais.
Fuko !
C'est Jean-Pierre !
Ah bon ?
Allô ?
Ici la sécurité du secteur Chung Chang...
Des espions... Ça se passe donc à Chung Chang...
On peut juste se souvenir que tout à l'heure pour un mec qui balayait....
Ils ont mis la musique la plus flippante du monde...
Et là, il y a quand même une alarme... et ils mettent des trompettes !
Ils se sont gourés ! Allez !
Allez à la guerre !
Prenez vos armes ! C'est trop ça !
Les kalashs, allez !
Madame...
Est-ce qu'on va attraper quelque chose ?
Aucun César !
Tu vas attraper aucun César en tout cas.
Il arrive tellement lentement !
Salut, alors ça mord ?
Ça ne marche pas du tout !
Il n'y a guère de poisson là-dedans.
Oui, c'est mieux que rien, hein ?
Bah non, si y'a rien... Donc, non...
Y'a pas de poisson, c'est mieux que rien...
Pas sur...
Madame, pensez-vous que les communistes vont venir ?
Je ne sais pas, il faut que nous...
C'est interminable cette réponse !
Je ne sais pas.
Il va y avoir une apparition de vaisseau spatiale. Est-ce que vous êtes tous prêts à voir cette entrée de champ ?
Ah oui parce que le système solaire, pour l'instant, on est un peu...
Oui alors on est quand même dans une école du Cambodge, quoi...
C'est bon, c'est beau !
Oui !
Ah donc...
Incroyable !
Ils avaient oublié des plans avec les comédiens donc ils ont dû les dessiner...
Est-ce qu'on est tous d'accord aussi que les dessins de... de gens... ces gens ont 27 ans ?
Alors que les comédiens avaient 8 ans...
Nous avons atterri en catastrophe... C'est Valérie ?
Cela dit c'est mieux que le film de Besson...
Je vois pas où est le problème.
vous êtes arrivés à vous échapper ?
On peut tous rappeler que...
Tous les comédies étaient asiatiques ?
Richard Gotainer !
Monsieur le Président...
Nous essayons de réunifier le pays mais cela semble difficile...
Vous allez y aboutir et il n'y aura aucun problème.
Il a un bourrelet de cou derrière...
Il a un kyste
C'est bien fait !
Qu'en pensez-vous ? Ils font des essais nucléaires, là, en fait...
Ça reste... le sujet actuel clairement.
Ça n'a pas pris une ride.
Il n'y a plus rien qui pourra nous en empêcher de gagner maintenant.
Sauf nous !
Ouais mais ils auront une piste...
Le signal d'alerte !
C'est une urgence, qu'allons-nous faire ?
C'est une urgence ! C'est...
Il est transparent le mec... Ouais, il y a un mec transparent dans l'arbre.
Avec de nouveau une musique...
Ouais, il y a zéro musique grave, hein...
Nous allons nous servir du métal pour construire notre propre robot.
Oui, Monsieur le Président.
Même les martiens ont des problèmes de calvitie...
1... 2... 3... 4...
5... 6...
C'est déjà trop... 7...
Général, vos pertes sont très importantes. Comment allez-vous m'expliquer ce carnage ?
Où se trouve les intrus ?
Dans le bourrelet !
Je te promets qu'aujourd'hui sera ton dernier...
Le poing disparait !
Batterie !
Il ne sait pas jouer !
Tu ne sais pas jouer de la percussion !
Je te conseille d'être très vigilant !
A vos ordres Capitaine !
Je te conseille d'être vigilant ! J'en ferai bien augure !
Vous êtes bien aimable !
Personne ne m'a jamais parlé ainsi. Il a une crotte de nez.
Fouettez-le un petit peu !
Fouettez-le un petit peu ! Un petit peu !
Un petit peu ! un tantinet !
Frappez-le mais de manière mesurée !
Rien à signaler !
Non mais... Rien à signaler !!
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette lumière qui clignote ?
Alors, il a deux voix... Il a la voix inspirée...
Et la voix ringarde !
Ça fait partie de ses devoirs de tout faire.
C'est vraiment systématique, dès qu'il y a une musique on s'emmerde !
Et comme il y en a depuis le début...
Il reste une heure de film...
C'est en hiver !
Elle te regarde l'air de dire "Quoi ?"
Transformation !
C'est un appareil photo géant ? Oui mais oui !
C'est un Konica !
Ah on l'a déjà eu ce plan !
Bah oui on l'a déjà eu... C'est un stylo plume géant !
C'est les mêmes plans.
Tu veux dire que... Ah ça arrive !
Oui, ils ont tous été détruits par un robot qu'on a pris pour un morceau de déchet au premier abord, quoi.
Le temps de se retourner si tu veux...
Un morceau de déchet...
Mais c'est un morceau de déchet ?
Ah non c'est un robot !
Et si tout ça n'était qu'un rêve...
Ce n'est qu'un rêve dans la tente.
Du début... Je pense... Je pense que tu as raison...
Tu as vraiment raison...
Tu as fait... Sans transition !
Mais c'est sur-bruiter ce petit poulet qui cuit !
En même temps, ce n'était qu'un rêve...
Je comprends rien. Ah non !
Mais non !
Venez manger, le petit déjeuner est prêt.
Oh, ce n'était qu'un mauvais rêve !
On est d'accord qu'ils ont filmé ça toute la journée...
Et que là, c'est le soir et ils se sont: "Merde on a pas fait de plan de... de..."
Ah bah clairement !
Clairement, la nuit est tombée !
Chantal Goya !
Ça c'est la fin, ça !
5...
4...
3... Trop vite !
Je vais applaudir un petit peu...
Prenons le temps de digérer tout ça...
Ouais, ce qu'on débriefe...
Je suis une peu chamboulée...
Bah moi c'est cette allégorie...
Communisme et tout ça, quoi...
C'est tout pour le feeling mais...
Moi c'est tout l'épilogue...
Vraiment...
Dans quel pays ça se passe, déjà ? Bah Chung Chang...
Moi, quand même ce qui m'a boulversée c'est la petite Cindy qui meurt au début.
Ah oui, c'est vrai que ça commence par une petite fille qui se fait tabasser !
Vous remarquez qu'il y a pas de générique...
Hé on l'a eu au début !
Pardon, tu veux parler des 25 premières minutes ?